hello everyone this here is a brilliant
game played by the Danish Grandmaster
Carsten Hawaii and he's playing against
a player who well who was much stronger
than him and he's playing against the
Soviet American grand master Boris buco
and the buco is actually the only player
ever to win the Soviet championship and
the United States Championship as well
and he also has a positive score against
Garry Kasparov three wins one loss and
four draws he even defeated Garry
Kasparov with the black pieces in a
miniature of I believe it's 24 moves so
that makes this game all the more
deserving for the Danish Grandmaster and
well the the attacking brilliancy of
this game can rival that of Morpheus
opera game so so let's see this beauty
Carsten is white and the mr. buco is
black so we have d 4e 692 f3 c5 e 3 and
92 f6
so transposing into the Indian game do
you suppose Rubinstein system Bishop to
d3 we have b6 castles the bishop to b7
Knight B to D to C capture some d 4e
captors on d4 and Bishop to e7
we have rook to e1 now black castles C 3
d6 Queen to e2 rook to e8 and now
tonight to f1 9b d7 9th to g3 and Bishop
to f8 with ideas of 'if I've so Bishop
to g5 a6 forcing white to show his
intentions with the bishop bishop goes
back to d2 and now Queen to c7 and we
have a bishop to see to Bishop to d5
would ideas of well Bishop to c4 maybe
or if the rook moves maybe even
capturing on a 2 but we have b3 not
allowing and now we have Queen to b7
what ideas of capturing this knight on
f3 we are nice to h4 avoiding this and
now b5 black doesn't want a lot way to
go for c4 we have pointed the
3.now threatening checkmate on h7 is
this Knight and f6 ever moves g5 of
forcing the knight back to f3
so Knight to f3 Bishop captures on f3 g
captures on f3 and now Bishop to g7
and well here white has a white has
several options he can maybe play a four
going for play on the Queen side he
could decide about as he does have
doubled pawns here these F ones are
doubled he could go for f4 maybe to open
up the King side but he goes for a more
direct approach
he plays h4 simply sacrificing a pawn
for opening the G file so we have G
captures on h4 and now Knight Knight to
e4 and well this is a pretty annoying
night here and well you do want to get
rid of it but what is attacking d6 here
and if you play something like Knight
captures on e4 you get rook captures on
e4 and this comes a good idea so maybe
rope to g4 or if f5 is played even rope
captures on h4 and this was well this
would improve whites whites attack on
the King side so after Knight to e4
attacking the six Queen to c6 is played
now defending the the pawn on d6 so King
to h1 this King is coming to h1 and this
is the diagonal the Queen is actually
controlling now but this is much less
important the important thing is to to
occupy this G file with the rook so
night to h5 and here we have worked g1
and here mr. Carson Hawaii employs his
brilliant attack we have came to f8 boku
wants to get away from this pin and mr.
high plays rook captures on g7 not
allowing taking any escape routes we are
King to e7 or King to d8 so what do you
play here well obviously you have to
capture the rook but how do you capture
the rook if Knight capture sin g7 then
Bishop captures on h6 now pinning this
night and well what do you play here is
black if rook d7 for example then simply
to g1 pinning this night and the wall
white is better here
so after this rook captures and g7 idea
Goku played King captures in g7 and here
well another brilliant move Bishop
captures on h6 forcing the King to the H
file and you do have to capture the
bishop I mean you don't want to play
King to g6 or H or 87 this would line up
the King for the discovery from this
night as the Queen and Bishop are ready
for the attack and well if you play
something like King to h8 you get Knight
captures and e6 and this is foreseen I
mean this is threatening checkmate on h7
also Knight captures on f7 is threatened
so after this Bishop captures I made six
idea King captures on h6 is played and
now the kingís has been forced to the H
file and rook the g1 cutting off the
Kings approach back into back where it's
safe and well Carsten had to see a lot
of moves ahead for this for this to be
even able to be played we have f5 here
and here again a very nice move Queen to
e3 kind of forcing white to push f4 so
he does he plays f4 and here white plays
Knight captures on d6 kind of looks like
he is sacrificing a queen but the Queen
cannot be captured if Queen if this pawn
captures the Queen then simply in knife
to f7 and this is checkmate and and the
beautiful checkmate the bishop and c2 is
covering h7 if you can see
so after this knife captures on d6 idea
you can't capture the Queen so boris
kukoba try the Queen captures on b6
capturing this night and now Queen to d3
and this comes with a threat of Queen to
g7 sorry Queen to g6 checkmate and also
Queen to h7 checkmate and how do you
stop this well you don't the only move
Black has really is night to g3 check
but rook captures night and the well
black is lost but boris galkin tried one
more move he played Knights to f8 and
this seems like it's protecting g6 and
h7 but it's really not here Karsten
Hawaii finishes this brilliancy with
Queen to h7 check and black king is
without squares only movies nice
captures on h7 and here we have the
final touch rook to g6 checkmate and I
mean look at this beautiful formation
the Knights are so close to the king but
they are useless in defending him so
yeah definitely a beautiful game and
well brilliancy by Karsten Hawaii
definitely but I will as I said Boris
buco was quite a player and that will
show a couple of Gokul games as well on
my channel so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check - on my previous videos here thank
you all for watching and I'll see you
soon